>> Betsy Peterson: To kick
us off I introduce myself.
I'm Betsy Peterson,
I'm the director
of the American Folklife Center.
And on behalf of
the staff I want
to welcome everyone here today.
This is the latest and
actually the last event
of the fiscal year in our
Botkin Lecture series.
And it's a very special
one I think.
It's called Since '68: Cultural
Organizations Programming
Documentation and
Community Enrichment.
And we've done a few events
throughout the year focusing
on events and movements, etc.,
related to 1968 and beyond.
And so this is one of them.
The Botkin series is
an opportunity for us
to present the very best
in folk life scholarship,
ethnomusicology, oral history,
and other related fields.
And to share them with you.
It's also an opportunity for
us to enrich our own archives.
All of these events
are tape recorded,
or video recorded I should
say, and will make their way
into our archives and also make
their way online eventually.
So with that said, please turn
off cell phones, if you would.
I'd appreciate it.
And one last thing, I just
want to say I'm so happy
that this is happening.
We have three organizations,
nonprofits,
started in the late 1960's.
Icons of cultural programming
of cultural work at a time
when nonprofits were just really
kind of getting their foothold.
And before the 1970's
when nonprofits,
cultural nonprofits all
nonprofits exploded.
It tripled, quadrupled
in the United States.
These folks were
there at the beginning
and these folks were figuring
out what the templates were.
Figuring out how to
work with communities
and present what they
needed and wanted.
And so I'm really pleased
that we have these
organizations with us today.
They deserve our thanks.
And so to tell you
a little bit more
about what this is I'm going to
turn this over to John Fen now.
But mainly I just
wanted to get up here
and say I think it's really
great that it's happening.
>> John Fenn: Thank
you very much, Betsy.
So greetings and
welcome to everyone.
My name is John Fen.
I'm the head of research
and programs
for the American Folklife Center
at the Library of Congress.
I'd like to extend thanks to
all of you in the audience,
all the staff at the library
who are working in support
of this event, and of
course our panelists.
Across these two panels we'll
hear from individuals involved
with three cultural
organizations that launched in
or shortly thereafter 1968.
Each of these organizations
anchor their activities
in community, culture,
and identity.
Rooting their menus of
programs and services
in the places stories and
heritages that surrounded them.
The idea for these panels
took shape via broader staff
discussions about 1968 and the
watershed of cultural activity
that emerged from that time.
Noting that the Center
for Traditional Music
and Dance celebrating
its 50th year
and that Appalshop is
getting ready to do the same.
We began thinking about
the roles of organizations
and what they've done in terms
of supporting cultural heritage.
From documenting to presenting,
training to advocating.
During the past 50 years
cultural organizations have
operated as vital resources
and spaces for communities.
Such organizations have
taken a range of shapes
and the three we'll
explore today began
as an ethnic art center, a media
collective, and a bookstore.
CTMD, Appalshop, and Drum
and Spear respectively.
The structure of each panel
is going to be the same.
We'll hear from individuals
representing the three
organizations, move into
a facilitated conversation
with across the full panel,
and then spend some time
with questions from
the audience.
There will be a short break
between panels at 2:30
and then we'll come
back together at 3:00.
I'll now introduce
those we've invited
to be part of the first panel.
And this panel is subtitled 50
Years of Cultural Programming
and Documentation: The Center
for Traditional Music
Advance and Appalshop.
From the center we have
Ethel Raim and Martin Koenig,
co-founders, joined
with Peter Rushefsky,
the executive director.
And then from Appalshop
we have Herb E. Smith,
one of the co-founders,
Alexander Gibson the
current executive director.
So I'm going to turn
it over to them.
I'm going to stay on stage as
the timekeeper and moderator.
CTMD will fill us in.
So please join me in
welcoming everyone.
Martin Koenig: You
know, it was --
the 60's were such a
different time in the states.
I guess in the world.
But here, the whole emerging art
scene really started taking off.
And it is so different
from today.
So for instance, the concept
of a Balkan Arts
Center occurred prior
to its technical launching.
So Ethel and I are
constantly arm wrestling
about when the Balkan
Arts Center started
because there is no specific
date that it technically --
well yes, there is a technical
date, which is in 1973.
That was the time that
we went to a lawyer
and they drew up the papers.
But part of that is because
even the federal government just
started funding the arts
through NEA in the mid 60's.
New York State started funding
in later than that, I believe,
or approximately the same time.
Folk arts divisions
got started even later.
So it wasn't on either
my radar screen,
or I think Ethel's,
anything about that.
But the concept of Balkan
Arts Center started earlier.
For me, I went to Bulgaria and
the Balkans to do research.
I fell in love with
the dance form.
And basically the first time
of the Balkan Arts Center,
the first stage of
the Balkan Art Center,
was devoted to research
and documentation,
and ultimately presentation
and publication,
which is what we
basically have always done,
but it was directed
towards Balkan dancing.
And for that I had a 501C3,
which was Margaret Mead,
the Institute for
Intercultural Studies.
So is Margaret Mead who
somebody wanted to give me $200
to help me on my
research in Bulgaria.
They made a contribution
to the Institute
for Intercultural Studies
and then Margaret Mead would
send me a check for $200.
And that happened through 1973.
And in 1973 -- or in
1972 I think it was,
the expansion arts program from
NEA gave, not Balkan Art Center,
but the Institute
for Intercultural
Studies a $5,000 grant,
which was then subcontracted
to the Balkan Arts Center.
And she said, "Well you've got
to form your own organization
now because your money is going
to be coming in and you're
going to expand your program."
So the first stage of the
Balkan Arts Center was devoted
towards dance.
And I can say from the very
beginning to where it's at now
that -- and I am
no longer working
with the Balkan Arts
Center but I'd been
on the board all the way
through, which is now the CTMD.
That it changed in 1970
when Ethel and I --
Ethel invited me to join
her to work with her
at the Smithsonian Institution
Festival American Folklife.
And that was where it expanded
from dance into communities.
And I had been doing five years
of field research in communities
in the Balkans, coming back
to the states and meeting
with families who were
hyphenated Americans here
in New York City,
and getting a sense
of what the communities
were here.
And coming with the sense
where the organization,
from the beginning,
was about community.
Was about building community.
Was about strengthening
community.
And the cement of all that
was the music the songs
and the dances.
And I think those four years
between '70 and '75, '74 we --
I think would not
be an exaggeration
that we spent seven
days a week together.
Sometimes up to 18 hours
a day together constantly
in these conversations.
Constantly working
in different cities.
Constantly working with
different families.
Constantly being in
church basements.
Constantly in traveling and
the Smithsonian was really
that gave us the opportunity.
That festival gave us the
opportunity to develop a model
that was serviceable for the
Balkan Art Center and we took it
and we kept going with that
model in how to do this work.
I think the next stage from
that would be in the late 70's
where we started doing
some tours and performances
with Jewish, Italian, Irish.
And we'd be asked,
"Balkan Art Center?
What does that got
to do with me?"
And we've been struggling
with names all along the way,
and that's where he came up
with the Ethnic Folk Art Center.
And eventually we came
-- still trying to --
that didn't quite
say it where CTMD,
Center for Traditional
Music and Dance came in.
And the next stage.
So the the stage in the 70's
and early 80's, mid 80's was
that it was still dealing with
European ethnic traditions.
And then there was a change in
the terrain that we were able
to go and work with all ethnic
communities, which is something
that we always wanted to do.
But the thinking was it could
happen at that point and I think
that really represents
the center which Pete
and Ethel will talk about.
That all ethnic communities
were embraced by the center
because the story is basically
the same with variations.
Anyway, I just wanted to
frame it in that way .
And I think the other
interesting thing
about this is Ethel and I are
both children of immigrants.
And immigrant music,
immigrant societies here,
we thought in the same way
politically with a small pea
to embrace and champion
those forms.
And it is interesting, we were
talking last night well nobody
really worked with
that up until the 60's.
So what we did with this
organization and are still doing
under Pete's leadership is
continuing to broaden the scope
of what's being done
and creating a model.
Because there was no model for
us in the work that we did.
And the reason we spent all
that time was there was nobody
to refer to and we were
creating something.
>> John Fenn: Go ahead.
>> Ethel Raim: I think that --
that really is a wonderful
frame for what we did.
Just concerned about the
time and 20 minutes and going
through these slides
and continuing.
So how are we on time?
>> John Fenn: About 13 minutes.
>> Ethel Raim: 13 minutes.
Let's let's start
with the slides
because the slides really
tell the story visually
and give you a sense of the
communities that we worked with.
The first slide, most of
the slides are by Martin,
who was a marvelous
wonderful photographer.
And we were incredibly
lucky that he had this skill
that he exercised the entire
time he was with the center.
This is a bride in
the Albanian community
and I would assume it's in
Brooklyn even though the church
at that time was on Park
Avenue in the Bronx.
So here we are at a wedding
with the bride well covered.
And this is dancing.
This is probably a
circumcision celebration
in the Albanian community
in Brooklyn.
And so the documentation
was to really capture life
in the community, and how the
community celebrates itself,
and how they go through
the calendar year.
And here's a woman outside and
this might be the Bronx now.
It looks like the Bronx.
I mean, you have to be
from the Bronx to know
that it looks like
from the Bronx.
And I'm from the Bronx and
Martin is from the Bronx.
>> Martin Koenig:
And so is Ethel.
>> Ethel Raim: I said I'm.
Okay and this is
[inaudible], wonderful singer
in the Albanian community,
playing not a [inaudible],
it's the one that's larger.
[Inaudible].
Yes. And so at this time we're
talking about the mid 70's here
through the -- just --
yeah, into the mid 70's.
This is the Bonnet
Romanian group.
Some of whom are
no longer with us.
The middle man is
not with us anymore.
[Inaudible], beautiful,
beautiful drummer
and person playing
music from the Bonnet.
Which was an independent region
in the former Yugoslavia.
And these musicians, the fella
with the accordion is
[inaudible], he was Serbian.
And Makkah wonderful singer.
And there is a [inaudible].
Not [inaudible].
[inaudible] and there's
[inaudible] at the end.
They call themselves
[inaudible].
I have to tell you there were
many groups in that community
that called themselves
[inaudible], Black Pearl.
And this is [inaudible]
if I'm not mistaken.
The Macedonian piper,
beautiful musician.
He was a dishwasher.
This photo was in the New
York Times and he came
in with the photo and
people said, "That's you?"
So I mean, the kind
of affirmation that,
and recognition that the
activities of the center did
with community people
was just marvelous.
And this is one of our most
favorite people in the world.
[Inaudible], he's no longer
with us a [inaudible].
He came in '74.
Martin and I met him and we
walked into a church in Yonkers.
And [inaudible], who was close
to six foot, wife [inaudible],
and his daughter and two sons.
An elegant family
walked into the church
and they were an elegant family.
Just incredible.
He was a marvelous musician.
Spoke Russian, and
Turkish, and Greek.
And here we are with
an archival --
and was a Heritage
Award winner yes.
And here's an archival
photo of Dave Terrace
on the right playing clarinet.
Martin, do you remember
which band this was.
>> Martin Koenig: No.
>> Ethel Raim: No.
Pete might know which
band it was.
>> Peter Rushefsky: I don't.
>> Ethel Raim: Anyone
in the audience?
>> Peter Rushefsky: I'm
not sure [inaudible] was.
>> Ethel Raim: It is Gratz on
the drums, yeah it is Irving.
Okay and here's Terrace when
he was -- I hate these words.
Rediscovered.
I mean. [inaudible]
music kind of with the --
with World War II and following
post war years [inaudible] was
not only in decline, it
wasn't happening at all.
Interestingly enough, it still
was happening in small quarters
in Europe which we
only found out,
you know, in the 50's and 60's.
So that was Dave coming
out of retirement.
And that program really was
a catalyst for revival --
revitalization, a better
word, of [inaudible] music in,
actually internationally.
This is [inaudible]
and a beautiful traditional
muted singer who used to perform
on the concerts that
we did with Dave.
And this is [inaudible]
playing a pisco.
Albanian Roma musician.
And he and his brother
played together.
They were marvelous,
marvelous musicians.
And they were up in
Waterbury, Connecticut.
And here we -- this
is when Martin talked
about the tour starting
about 1981.
Was our first tour of Italian
musicians and [inaudible] worked
with us and we actually
got money
from the Italian government
to pay the artists' lost work
wages which was wonderful.
And these are two guys from
Sicily and a guy on the right is
from Rhode Island, Angelo.
And this is Cherish the Ladies.
A very early photograph --
Eliene Ivra right there in
the middle Joni Madam right
in the back in the
center, and the dancers.
And Mary Coogan is there
who played the Heritage Festival
this year at Lincoln Center.
And this photo was probably
just after the concert in 1985.
And Joni, who came up with the
name of the group, she said,
"Ethel Noes going
to come to see us."
We turned 400 people
away from that concert.
And I don't know his name,
the Garifuna community.
Martin, you took this photo?
>> Martin Koenig: I took
the photo [inaudible].
>> Ethel Raim: No.
Okay. Oh and this
is early [inaudible]
and there is Juan Gutierrez
on the right, sitting.
[inaudible], who's
no longer this us.
A beautiful dancer.
And Roberto Cepeda in
the middle on the drum.
Just gorgeous musicians.
And Juan started his
own organization.
And his daughter is very active
in that organization, Julia.
And this is Manny
Ocenda and we're
at Harbor Festival
which was 1986.
Celebration of the centennial
of the Statue of Liberty.
And we've programmed four
stages for over four days.
And this is Nidhi Horta,
beautiful Puerto Rican musician.
Part of a group called
El [inaudible].
And this is our first matters
on our -- five minutes.
I better go faster.
At Brooklyn Museum --
Brooklyn Arts Museum.
And one of the things that
we realized we needed to do,
even though it was, it had its
own tension, was to be able
to collaborate with larger
institutions and find venues.
And of course the newspaper
would give the institution the
credit and no mention of CTMD,
but those are the shakes.
Can you go back just
one quickly.
Right, so this is
still [inaudible].
These are three brothers from,
[inaudible] brothers from Iraq.
>> Martin Koenig: Yemen.
>> Ethel Raim: Yemen.
Thank you.
And this is Middle Eastern
ensemble with Simone Shaheen
up there with the violin and
Youssef Qassab on [inaudible]
and George -- some of those
people aren't with us anymore.
This is Pedro.
This is at El Museo
del Barrio and this is
from the Dominican
community and part
of the Dominican cultural
initiative that we did.
We did about 12 or 13 of
those where we would work
for five years at a time within
a community to help foster,
and sustain, and
promote traditional arts
within the community.
This is dance India that
was at Hunter College.
That's [inaudible]
in the middle.
And the next slide is DJ Rica
who had this fortress incredible
career after this program
with SOB and her
basement Bhangra.
Here we are at Heritage
Sunday Lincoln Center
and that's Nina Paolina
on the left.
That was part of the
Dominican initiative
and this is part of
the West African.
If I'm talking fast, sorry.
This is -- that was [inaudible]
and that was an initiative
that went on for five years.
And this is [inaudible] and this
is Lincoln Center out of doors,
our Heritage Festival.
And then this was a time that we
were doing a program called Folk
Parks, which grew out of our
Queens Ethnic Music Dance
Festival, which grew out
of the Winter Folk Festival
and the Spring Folk Festival.
And these are Korean artists
also at Lincoln Center.
This is Thunderbird Dancers
whom we've been working with,
probably, I don't know,
20 years at least by now.
Maureen, correct
me if I'm wrong.
And this is producer
[inaudible],
a wonderful Bukharian
dancer and very active.
She ran a restaurant
in Manhattan for years.
Beautiful dancer.
And this is [inaudible] from
Bulgaria, part of the movement
of Bulgarian wedding music.
And that's Katherine
Foster up there on clarinet,
Lauren Brodie off to the left.
And Jerry, just stay on
the slide for a minute
because this is indicative
of musicians who come
when the community is not here
yet and so they find Americans
who play their music and that's
exactly what happened here.
So three are unaffiliated
Americans.
[Inaudible], Bulgarian
on accordion.
Okay and this is
-- oh, two minutes.
Okay give or take.
I like the give.
>> Martin Koenig: Or take.
>> Ethel Raim: Or the take.
Ramon Ponce Sr. and this is the
Mariachi Academy of New York.
An organization that was spawned
out of Community
Cultural Initiative
in the Mexican community.
And Ramon is now running three
academies in New York City,
in Brooklyn and New Jersey.
Well he's trying for
one in New Jersey.
One in Queens and
one in Manhattan.
Okay. And this is our
Peruvian arts program,
Pachamama Peruvian Arts.
And this is one of the
children that participate.
And the nice thing about some
of the more recent
cultural initiatives is
that we've started teaching
programs and that is really
in response to what the
community wants in terms of,
we want our children
to know our culture and
and all they're getting
is this other stuff.
And you can fill in the
other stuff yourself.
This is music from China,
Susan Chang there on the left.
Whom we worked with and also
did a sharing traditions
program with.
And there's [inaudible] teaching
kids to play [inaudible].
And at [inaudible] Center,
which is another Chinese
initiative in New York City.
And can we have [inaudible],
Colombian.
And that was probably our 11th
or 12th community
cultural initiative.
And this is Maurice Canate,
beautiful drummer
and beautiful person.
Very active in the
Colombian initiative.
This is [inaudible]
Augustine, Haitian drummer
who also won a national heritage
fellowship many years ago.
And one says the
[inaudible] festival
that happens pretty
independently
in Prospect Park in Brooklyn.
And is a very important
sacred celebration
that happens every August.
And Sri Lanka.
Now this is probably from
this year, right, Maureen?
And these are the Sri
Lankan Dance Academy
and I -- in Staten Island.
And that's where one
of the largest Sri Lankan
communities resides,
is in Staten Island.
Okay. Finished with the -- I'm
going turn this over to Pete
so he can do something
in the next 30 seconds.
>> Peter Rushefsky:
I'll swap out --
>> Martin Koenig: I'll punt.
>> Peter Rushefsky:
I do have some time.
Okay. Well I don't -- I don't
have too much to offer on top
of that introduction other
than everyday we really feel,
in the office that we're sort
of walking on the shoulders
of giants of the two
individuals to my right who's,
you know the the things they had
to build from scratch we sort
of take that take advantage.
And I can't say we take for
granted because we do remember,
but you know, it's just
remarkable how a lot of things
that we do every day are
really, you know, the same kind
of things, the same
kind of conversations,
the same issues you were dealing
with 50 years ago, 40 years ago,
30 years ago we're
doing it today.
We have new tools to work with.
We have new technologies.
The people are different.
I just want to thank Maureen
Walker and our deputy director
who has been wonderful to work
with over the last two years.
But Maureen and I
are having a lot
of the same conversations
every day that Marty
and Ethel had 45 years ago
and it's and it's a pleasure.
It's a it's a really -- it's
a real privilege for us.
So.
>> John Fenn: Great.
So, thank you CTM.
We are going to pivot the
Appalshop over to Kentucky
and then come back
together and cover some
of those overlapping questions.
So I'm going to turn it
over to Herb E. Smith
and Alexander Gibson.
You guys are going.
>> Herb E. Smith: I
agreed to be first
since I'm 66 years
old and Alex isn't.
>> Alexander Gibson: It
creeps up on you, though.
It creeps up on you.
>> Herb E. Smith: So
in 1969, I was a senior
at Whiteburg High School.
A 17-year old student.
And this guy arrived
in our town.
I think the sign
said 1,400 people
at that time, kind
of small town.
And he had this film
like an equipment.
And we were just like
fascinated, you know,
what could we do
with this stuff.
It was more about
learning the technology
than anything else at first.
You know, you ever seen the
kids that have never been
around a computer and then
they got get a hold of it
and then they go see
what they can do with.
That's kind of the way we were.
And so it turns out there
was this outfit based
in New York City that had
sent this equipment our way.
It's called Community
Film Workshop Council
and it had been started by
the American Film Institute,
which had been started
in the offices
of the National Endowment
for the Arts.
So we were like two or three
steps down from the beginning
of the arts endowment,
which I think starting '65.
And I think AFI was
'67 and we were '69.
And -- but we kind of had --
they had this idea of
vocational education.
And there was a realization
that the range
of people behind the
cameras was too narrow
to represent the country, right.
And we've got a big
country out there with a lot
of different people in it and
there was a very narrow slice
of that population that was
in the production
rooms recording sound,
shooting the cameras, editing.
You know, all of the
work that it took
to make the films were mainly
urban people in big cities.
And we were in this
small town which I've --
okay we got this
equipment, now what can we do
with that that's different
from what those other
people were doing with it.
And of course one of the things
that became obvious right
off the bat was that we felt
like somehow the television
portrayals of us were wrong.
Like when Appalshop started
there was Beverly Hillbillies
on the television, Hee
Haw, Green Acres, you know,
all of the Hollywood stuff.
Li'l Abner, all the cartoons.
And there was just
a open ridicule
of our people in the media.
And so we thought, "Well
we have a job to do.
We got to set this right."
So we -- so they started calling
it Community Film Workshop
Council of Appalachian.
And we said, "No, no, no.
We'll call it Appalachian
Film Workshop."
And then we did that
for a few months
and then we said,
"That's too long.
We'll just leave out the
achian, the film, and the work.
And we're kind of
like Appalshop."
And that's what we did.
And so we formed our own
little Board of Directors
and then sure enough -- so what
had happened was Community Film
Workshop Council was
funded by the Office
of Economic Opportunity.
So who's got that?
Office of Economic Opportunity.
OEO. You all have heard of that?
So it was the war on poverty.
There's the agency
created by LBJ
to spearhead the war
on poverty, right.
And so start thinking
for a second.
We started in '69.
LBJ is not the president
anymore, right.
Nixon's elected in ,68.
Takes office in January '69.
Well they start putting
pressure,
the Nixon administration on
Community Film Workshop Council
in New York City
saying, "We are okay
with the vocational
education side of this
but this community based
expression stuff, we don't like.
And who knows, they
might be making films
against strip mining, or
they might want to kind
of like have mine
safety, or they want
to prevent black lung disease,
or all this other stuff
that they'd be making
films about."
So Nixon administration
wasn't going to have it.
So then we split off with the
New York people and we said,
"We'll just go our
own separate way."
Which we did in '71.
Anyway, that's kind
of how we started.
It was kind of a wild ride
but we were pretty political
right off the bat in the sense
of knowing that we were
in a tumultuous time.
People getting killed, city's
going up in smoke, Vietnam War.
And we felt like there
should be a voice
from the coal fields
of Appalachia.
And we tried to be that.
>> Alexander Gibson: Yeah
and I think there's a
couple other unique pieces
of the beginning of Appalshop.
My name is Alex.
I've been with Appalshop
for about four years now.
I come from eastern Kentucky
from tobacco country.
Which is about an hour and a
half, probably 45 minutes away
from Whitesburg if we
could sprout wings.
But because the way the
mountains go, it takes probably
about two hours to get there.
And it's tobacco country
instead of coal country,
which doesn't seem significant
if you're not from the area
but it's pretty big culturally
different sort of thing.
There's a couple other pieces
about Appalshop's founding
that I find unique
because it's, you know,
it's been here for 50 years.
So when Appalshop moved
in and Herb E. mentioned
if I forget something,
Whitesburg had a
pretty strong economy.
It had U.S. Steel,
RC Cola, Coca Cola.
Am I forgetting anything
else big?
>> Herb E. Smith: The
schools are the biggest
employers probably.
>> Alexander Gibson:
The schools.
And you know, all that except
for schools is gone now.
And Appalshop is still there.
Coal, you know, was the
largest employer in the region
and the largest moneymaking
force in the state.
In that part of the
country, in fact.
And had incredible
political power.
Still has incredible
political power everywhere
that mining still occurs.
And Appalshop the, you
know, plunky artists
that don't really impact
the economy, quote unquote,
grew while everything
else shrank.
And I think there's some
reasons why that's the case.
And some of them are
wrapped up in the founding.
And so, two I think, interesting
elements came together.
One if the kind of -- the nature
of Appalachian folks as well
as people of low
income everywhere to try
and scrap together what you
need to get the job done.
And that maybe duct tape, it
may be you fix your own thing.
You make your own widget.
It may be buying widgets
from D.C. Hitchhiking up here
to raise money like Herb
E. did some years ago.
And the other thing was the
background of the founder.
The first person.
Bill Richardson came down from
Yale, he was an architect.
That's an interesting background
to come into film making.
And at the architecture school
at Yale he was introduced
to the importance
of other art forms.
Radio, photography.
He had to take these courses.
He had to integrate
that into his work
in the architecture school.
And so then Apple shop started
as a, like we mentioned,
a documentary film workshop
meant to document and talk about
and explore the area as well
as provide real job training
for young people in the
mountains that was different
than the majority for
what was readily available
which at the time was cold.
Well as anybody here
who is involved
in nonprofit fundraising, you
know that there were cycles.
You know, there will be
buzzwords that are useful
for 10 years and then,
like vocational training,
workforce development,
etc. And these are cycles
that impact some
arts organizations
in an existential way, you know.
If you if you orient yourself
around workforce development
for whatever ethnic group
or population sector
that you want to, you know,
could be 10 years from now
that some new think
tank has decided
that that's not the way to go.
Instead you need
technological training
or something else well
Appalshop and the fact
that we had this kind of
background meant that,
you know, we started in '69.
We added a radio station
not that long after.
Youth media training.
I think AMI was the
first, wasn't it?
It's a youth media training
where we basically recreated
the Appalshop process
where you had the
filmmaker come and hand
out cameras to young people.
Well we created an
organization with an Appalshop
to do this same thing
and it's been going now.
It's still going.
We added music education,
traditional music education.
We've had many different
programs over the years.
And as those cycles of
funding went, we had the,
this sort of Appalachian
-- it's not --
again, it's not just Appalachian
but I'm just describing
a situation
where people have less income
and they need to figure
out a way to get things to work.
Well you know, if our
radio was well funded
than our radio we try to
partner with our filmmakers
and do projects like that.
And so we could survive
funding cycles
because we were big
enough, we were diversified
in our portfolio to be able
to absorb some losses
in the market, right.
And the rest of the
organization could rise.
So I think that is pretty
unique about Appalshop
and how it's been
able to survive.
I think the other piece is
that our fundamental
mission is not satisfied
and it won't be until,
you know --
so, into into what we
do, like Herb E. said.
What's the -- what --
how am I doing on time?
Okay. So baked in -- and
I'm not going to talk
about slides by the way.
So just enjoy them
on your own time.
But baked into our idea is
this idea of ridicule, right.
It was part -- Herb E. spoke
about it in the past tense
and of course all of you know
that that's not a
past tense question.
We're ridiculed practically
every time we're on television.
Is just to find some new
way to make the point
that we are racist or a
misogynist or backward or angry
about international trade or
immigrants or no one really.
But in fact we all know,
all of all of the
educated folks here know
that all those things
are just silly.
That there is no
job competition.
That that's just imaginary.
That there is no --
again, I grew up on a farm.
So my background of seeing labor
change is in my actual history.
So I think that the lack of
communication back and forth
between these sorts of sectors
of our society is what gives
rise to the stereotypes.
And Appalshop has been
focused on addressing
that for a long time
and unfortunately there's not
more media that comes out of
that part of the country and
the problems seem to persist.
The divide seems to not subside
and I think our country
suffers for that fact.
So you know, really baked
into the concept of Appalshop
to go back to the phrase I
used earlier, is this idea
of differences in power
and differences in access.
And so how do you
reset the stage?
How do you provide that access?
How do you provide opportunities
to people who, you know,
wouldn't have the
best museum access,
or after school programs, or
private schools, or you know,
what do you do to a
historically ignored population.
What's the method to amplify?
And the biggest damage that's
done there is not political,
it's very personal.
You know, people
grow up like me.
Like most people in the region.
Most young people who grow
up and they hate the region.
You know, they see the
television and they think
of themselves through that lens.
And so part of the work that
we do is to explore that.
And so you'll see people
at the end of, you know,
we take young people
and we give them
that youth media education
program I was discussing
and you'll see them go
through the process of thinking
about the region,
debating the region,
thinking about them they're
placed in the region,
and then sort of coming to
some sort of cathartic moment
at the end .So all
these things, you know,
the problems still persist
and in a similar way
caused by similar problems.
And part of Appalshops work, the
final piece that I'll mention
that I think adds to this
and then I'll pass it back
over to Herb E., is you know,
a very early understanding
that our problems
shared commonality
with poor folks across
the world.
And particularly, communities
that where extraction
takes place.
But it's not it's not limited
to a sort of mineral extraction.
But it's the idea that in order
for, you know, economic systems
as we currently understand them
to run, they need to be fueled
by low cost labor for
minerals that can then turn
into second order products
in some urban center
or manufacturing place and
then maybe into a third
or fourth order product
and sold.
Well we're the first, right.
We're the first line in that.
We're the coal, we're the
timber, we're there --
and so bauxite in
Jamaica, right.
Coal and Wales.
Gold in West Africa.
Diamonds in Central
and East Africa.
I mean, the nature of
extractive processes power
and then the people that extract
is almost identical everywhere.
And it depends on, you know,
it seems to be the limit
as what is the company
allowed to get away with
and that's the point
that they'll go to.
That seems to be my experience
and so Appalshop understanding
this kind of commonality,
put us into a much
bigger partnership pool
than we otherwise would deserve
given our location, you know.
So we have partners
all over the world
of all different ethnic groups.
And that's really been an
informative process to our work
and I think has helped to
keep us agile and current.
And again, I just,
I feel very similar
to if -- Paul, is that right?
>> Peter Rushefsky: Pete.
>> Alexander Gibson: Pete.
Sorry. I feel very similar
to Pete that, you know,
I'm here talking about
stuff that everyone,
that other people
around me have done.
And so it's a very
humbling experience to be
in the presence of people.
You know, my first encounter
with Appalshop was 16 years old.
I was at Berea College
in Kentucky
for a summer program
with Upward Bound.
And people were so familiar
with this self-hatred
of the Appalachian young
person that you had --
we did this entire week of
education on Appalachia.
And it was, okay, what
does Appalachian mean?
Let's do a sort of in depth --
let's look at this construct.
Let's look at the
geographical region
and does the geography
match the culture
and so then where's the cultural
region and what are we talking
about when we talk Appalachia?
Are we talking about the
New York Appalachian range?
Are we talking about
the southern parts?
Are we thought my
Georgia, Birmingham?
What does this mean?
What's this concept?
And so that week was
a sort of deep dive.
And you could have -- that
week was called something
like Appalachian
Orientation Week.
It could have been called
Appalshop Orientation Week
because it was Appalshop film,
after Appalshop film,
after Appalshop film.
And you know, in that region
there's really not a lot else.
So, like Herb E. said, there's
a lot of negative medium
and it was the first time in my
life that I was asked to think
about these complicated
questions about the region.
And then by doing that, I was
sort of able to go outside
of myself and look at the region
as a constructive
part of an economy.
A constructive part
of an economy.
That sort of eye opening I
think is what a lot of people go
through when they go
through Appalshop programs
or when they're exposed
to our materials.
It's to think broader
than your background.
And to explore these really
difficult complex projects
to tell stories that amplify,
educate folks around us.
And I'll pass it back to Herb
E. now for the final piece.
>> Herb E. Smith: I wanted
to just say a word or two
about the importance of
scholars in our work.
You grow up in a place and you
know a certain amount of --
you know, you get some
stuff by osmosis, right.
You didn't -- you're not going
to learn it from your brothers
and sisters and cousins
and aunts and uncles
and grandparents and, you know
just the network of friendship
and kinship in a given place.
You found out some
things about a place.
But then there's a whole bunch
of stuff that you don't know.
And we began to find out that
there were people who were
like going back and
reading all these documents.
Like when the deeds
got signed over,
and how did the coal
companies ended
up with the mineral rights,
and how did the building
of these towns happen, and
who's owning the place.
And for us, we were like whoa.
And then there was a guy named
Archie Green you had just
written a book a few years
earlier called Only a Minor.
And Archie came into
Whitesburg and he's like sitting
down with us and
talking about how we had
to like listen to
those scholars.
And we were like, "They
don't know nothing.
They got it all wrong, Archie."
And he's -- Archie says,
"Hold on a second, Herb E..
Just go slow here."
And I remember we were visiting
a small college in the region.
And there was a folklorist
there.
And the folklore said
something about, "Archie,
why is it that you're always
intervening in these processes.
That there's a natural
process that happens
as traditions change."
And Art says, "What
are you talking about?"
And he said, There's two buck
deers fighting in the woods.
Are you going to take sides
with one or the other?"
And Archie said, "If the
woods on fire I'm going to go
out there and try to
put the fire out."
And that's what we thought
we were we were trying to do.
We were trying to
put the fire out.
>>John Fenn: Thank
you very much.
So a round for all
of our speakers.
Now we'll shift here and as
I'm trying to connect some
of those themes that have
come up in both presentations
with individual organizations
looking -- oh wait.
Maybe I should have --
Maureen, could you hit
that screen darkener button?
That worked seamlessly before.
Oh okay. Just keep trying.
Whatever. So there's
some framing questions
that I had given to the
panelists before and a lot
of them are going to, I
think, push us to think
about some specific examples
of some of the things
that you've all discussed.
So I'll pitch the
first one out here
and then we can think about it.
So looking back over
the past five decades,
how has either organization
shifted activities in response
to changing cultural
environments?
And I think as you were going
through the decades, Ethel,
some things were kind
of beared in there
as you guys were pivoting.
And I'd like you guys
to think about that too.
So which -- who wants
to go first?
Who wants to take that one?
>>Alexander Gibson: I
could just say that --
I mean, I'd be interested
in Ethel and Marty on this.
What they have to say obviously.
But you know, our, we just
did a series of programs back
in New York on the, it
was the 50th anniversary
of the Heart Cellar Act, which
changed immigration patterns
in this country in
a fundamental way.
And I think now almost half
of Americans can directly
relate their family narratives
to immigration stories
to that act.
Which changed immigration from
being basically just from parts,
certain parts of Western Europe.
Or if you had family
members who are already
in this country it
opened up the immigration
to the hemispheric quota --
new atmospheric quota systems.
So all of a sudden we're
seeing people come from places
in large numbers that
you hadn't seen before.
So like for instance, the
Balkans and then, you know,
expanding out from there.
I don't know.
Ethel and Marty, does that
sort of resonate with you?
The -- was there something new
going on back in 19, the period,
the mid sixties, immigration
wise that inspired your work?
>> Ethel Raim: Absolutely.
I mean, that was a time.
1965, the Balkan Art Center,
Ethnic Folk Art Center,
Center for Traditional
Music and Dance.
I mean, I totally benefited
from that immigration
and the work was cut out for us.
We were working primarily with
first-generation Americans
who were spectacular
carriers of their traditions.
Musicians, dancers, I mean,
you went to a community event
and it was an organism
that was working in concert
and in synchrony that
was pretty extraordinary
and that was community.
And the biggest changes
that I see, really,
is working with second, third,
and fourth generation
immigrant population as well
as new immigration
is still happening.
And as immigration is one of the
top issues in the world today.
I mean, the amount of displaced
people and and transference
and population movement.
I mean, I don't think we -- I
mean, there was huge movement,
of course, after World War I.
And I don't know how
that compares to that.
This period of movement
to that but it's huge.
And people need to be grounded
and be given the opportunity.
And so issues of access are
across both of our
organizations.
Access, power structure, I mean,
one of the things that Martin
and I always talked
about was, you know,
there were no immigrant
artists on TV, you know,
or in concerts or anywhere.
And so we didn't -- many, many
concerts, and concert series,
and tours of concerts,
and festivals.
And lo and behold, 20 years
later, BAM has ethnic arts,
and the immigrant arts,
and Lincoln Center,
and Carnegie Hall, and
it's wonderful, you know.
So that -- we were the
incubator, so to speak.
Or the catalyst.
Both actually.
And other institutions became
responsive and carried forward.
But it's still going
to be an issue.
And again, it's how to work
with immigrant populations
that are now in third
and fourth generation.
That's one of the major
issues that I see, and change.
>> Martin Koenig: Well if I
can just piggyback on that.
And I must say, when we first
started receiving our grants
from NEA, Appalshop
was always referred to.
And an Appalshop
would always be spoken
about in the same sentence
that the Balkan Art
Center is spoken about.
And hearing you speak.
I'm very moved.
Because your mission
was our mission.
As Ethel spoke, we didn't
see ourselves on TV.
We didn't hear our
music on the radio.
And that's very difficult now
because now you've got
world music, the ethnic pop.
You've got all these forms out
that's very fashionable to go
into a club and you hear
music from around the world.
But in 1960's America,
we weren't there.
We knew that immigrants
built this country
but immigrant music was not --
there was no exposure to it.
And if timing is everything,
we benefited from the timing
of the bicentennial
coming up in 1976.
So the federal government
was putting money out there
to have a big party to
celebrate ourselves.
And the Smithsonian was
supported and was given a budget
to prepare this great
celebration of our greatness.
And today it's a
very different world.
And I don't know where
it's going, quite frankly.
It's -- I'm totally
confused by it.
Well I don't think
I'm the only one.
I would also like to say that
we've been a distant supporter,
if I could say the word.
I just always admired what
work you all have done.
And you know, it's a
big country out there.
And there's -- even within
the Appalachian region,
there's a lot of diversity that
doesn't go recognized often.
And you know, these
mining towns,
they have all kinds
of people in them.
And some sense that there's
this remote enclave of people
who are somehow not a part
of the rest of the country.
I think, you know, you just
at some point realize how
completely wrong it is.
These ideas about who we are and
the places that we're a part of.
So I think -- another thing I
wanted to mention for us was
that we also saw it
as a economic task
that we weren't just
about making films
or supplying a certain,
you know.
We ended up with radio station,
theatre company, and so forth.
And -- but we thought
that if we were going
to revitalize the homeland, that
we had to model best practices.
And that today, we have about
a million dollars in payroll
in a town of 2,000,
2,500 people.
And it shows up on
the map in Whiteburg.
And to us, that's really, really
important because it's not
that we're going to lie.
It's a plant in the
coal industry.
But we can figure out ways
to live in those mountains
and not be subservient
to those powerful forces.
>> John Fenn: So picking
up on this theme of change.
I'm going to jump one
of the other questions.
And again, you've each sort
of addressed this somewhat,
especially with the
community music initiatives.
But how is it each organization
integrated community
perspectives into
documentation projects
and cultural programming
initiatives?
So not just necessarily
presenting them representing
them, but hearing feedback
from the communities
and the constituents
who are working with
and then rolling with it?
>> Alexander Gibson: Okay.
Well, all of our
programs at Center
for Traditional Music and Dance.
I mean, all are really
based in creating a process
for a dialogue to happen
between the organization,
and different immigrant
communities, or you know,
whatever sort of community
we're dealing with.
Usually immigrant in
ethnic communities.
And so for most of our projects
we have, you know, we jump --
we don't just jump in with
programs of documentation.
We're doing, you
know, eight months
to a year of field research.
So folks on our staff,
or we work with consulting
folklorists,
and people who have done
work in the community.
You know, we -- that's
usually the --
the way we find out
about what's emerging
in different communities.
And you know, as well as a lot
of research, you know, with,
you know, looking at, you know
what the New York Times is
reporting on different
communities, looking at census,
statistics, and things
like that.
Finding out from our friends
what new restaurants are
out in Jackson Heights
and things like that
that we should go check out.
But you know, it's really, you
know, we're spending a good deal
of time, really, you know, diet,
you know, ultimately meeting
with community members.
Interviewing them.
Finding out what's
important to them.
Finding out, you know,
what scholarships been done
on a particular community.
And then once that's --
that sort of baseline
research has happened,
we create project committees.
So we've had these community
cultural initiatives now we've
rebranded them as program
called Sustaining Cultures
but it's very, you know, on
the same theme where we're --
we have a -- bring together
groups of anywhere from eight
to 12 community members
who are meeting regularly.
And so the curation of the
programs, the identification
of what needs to be
documented and how it needs
to be documented
and disseminated.
That's really coming --
it's coming from the
community members
and we provide a toolkit.
We -- because we've done
this work in, you know, 15,
20 different ethnic communities
and so we have a, you know,
a track record and know how
about the things that work.
And how to get funding
for it of course.
And -- but they're really
telling us, you know,
how to kind of direct
those resources.
And that's the -- I mean,
that's what's wonderful
and the greatest
pleasure of the work.
I mean, our you know,
when we put on a concert,
the concert is just
the tip of the iceberg.
It's really what underpins that
is often years of research years
of building relationships
with community members.
And you know, and Marty
and Ethel and I often talk,
you know, some of the some
of the musicians that Marty
and Ethel were working back in
the late 60's and early 70's.
We're working with the
grandchildren of those musicians
who are now great musicians
and artists in their own right.
So to have that sort
of longitudinal
inter-generational dialogue
about, you know,
with communities it's what
makes the work so, I think,
so important, so rooted in the
expressions of the community.
And just such a pleasure
to work with, you know,
as a folk arts professional
working in this field.
So.
>> Martin Koenig: Well one of
the things that I would say is
that Appalshop is largely
an organization of people
who are making things.
So there's filmmakers,
there's people
who are producing
radio programs.
We have live DJ's that broadcast
24/7 on our radio station.
We have a theater company
that's producing new plays.
We have a youth media
program that's producing five
or six short videos that the
youth have chosen the topics
and making short
pieces about the place.
And one of the things
about making stuff is
that there's a pleasure to that.
That it's kind of like
the guy at the foul line.
You know what he really wants?
Is the pleasure of seeing
the ball go through the net.
You just, you know, he's
like, I pulled it off.
I took -- undertook
this hard thing.
The crowds yelling, you
know, and you're kind
of trying to win the game.
But you what you really
like is when the ball goes
through the net and you're
like, I did it, you know.
I was able to accomplish
something that was difficult.
Now that has to be
in the context
of some community
support and blah, blah,
blahs in response to you.
>> Alexander Gibson:
But I think it's also
that it accomplishes something
with communities [inaudible].
>>Martin Koenig: Exactly.
>> Alexander Gibson:
It's not easy.
It takes years.
>>Martin Koenig: That's right.
>> Alexander Gibson:
And multi --
I mean, the notion of
multi-generational contact
and presence has come up
across both organizations too.
Which I think is the
key to longevity.
>>Martin Koenig: Now it makes
sense to me that before she got
into folk arts, a little
known fact, Ethel Raim was
with the CCNY City College
of New York basketball team.
Believe it or not.
I think she played center too.
>> Alexander Gibson: And
the community piece is very
important in Appalshop's
background in history,
given coal was the, you
know, a big force --
you know, I'm trying to
think of a good metaphor.
Elephant in the blah,
blah, blah.
You know, you get the point.
It was big.
It's big, and important,
and powerful .
And it was the context
for a lot of our work.
And you know, that sort of
thing as well as growing
up the color I am and
the place I grew up,
made me think quite a bit about
the concepts of community.
And that's sort of what I
meant when I was saying,
how do you draw Appalachia?
Right? It's an interesting
question.
Are the coal companies
part of our community?
You know, we've integrated
their perspectives.
It doesn't mean that we
agree with their perspectives
and that's true across
the board.
So and you know, is racism part
of our cultural heritage
in Appalachia?
Yes. I would say it's also true
in D.C. but that being said,
it's part of our
cultural heritage.
Women leading and and women
being kept from leadership.
Both of which are part
of our cultural heritage.
And we'll have people that
we work with who hold beliefs
that we don't necessarily
agree with.
And our question -- the
challenge for us always is,
okay if we're going to
address a particular topic,
we're to pretend that
these people don't exist.
And further, we're not going
to create a documentary
where the purpose is to be God
and tell you what to
think and believe.
Nor are we going to
make a documentary
that ridicules our own people.
So how do you do
all those things?
How do you get a sympathetic
coal position into a piece
without cutting them up and
making them look foolish
and then creating a piece
that's honest to the region.
Maybe doing that is what creates
the honesty to the region.
Maybe not having the voice
over telling you what
to think is what
creates the honesty.
But all of these artistic
questions are asked
because of the democratic
questions underneath.
Because what we're
doing here is democracy.
That's what we see
ourself, as participating
in a fundamental
piece of democracy
and that's what we see the --
the reason that we
were created was
because something was broken.
And community is just
really, it's really tough --
it's one of the reasons I
didn't want to not answer any
of these questions but
it's a tough one for me
because I don't know whether I
think community is an arbitrary
line we draw or whether it's
something that's immovable
yet -- you know, is the Bronx a
distinct community from Queens
or is it one particular street.
I mean, at what point -- if
you're Irish were you part
of it -- were you always part
of it and people just didn't
like it or -- so those are
difficult questions for me.
But there's no doubt that the
whatever community is it's
fundamental to what we do.
And that's a very
awkward phraseology
but we an Appalshop will debate
these questions all the time.
What is our community?
What's our obligations
to our community?
Yeah. Sounds like we're
the same organization.
We just do.
>> Martin Koenig: It's
variations on the theme.
>> John Fenn: But it's
a large network, yeah.
>> Alexander Gibson: Yeah.
>> John Fenn: Okay I'll pitch
just one more framing question
then maybe see what
things haven't come
up that you guys have
been listening to.
So the futures has come
up a little bit here.
Looking ahead ,what do you see
as the kinds of programming,
documentation projects, training
projects your organization
should be pursuing?
So if we're looking ahead for
the next 10 years or 50 years,
you know, you can choose
your own time frame.
But I know Ethel's hit on some
things like the changing nature
of demographics and
my great, you know,
immigration patterns
is something key.
But what are some other things
that either organization is
looking at right now coming
out of this sort of 50
year-ish celebration?
>> Peter Rushefsky: Back to me.
All right.
I'll take it.
Which reminds me actually,
Ethel always, you know, says,
poses the question, you have
two ways to learn to operate
in the present in your own
present and plan for the future.
One is, you can forget the past
or you could actually
learn about the past.
And that doesn't mean you
live your present and build
to your future in a
backwards looking way
but you can use an informed way.
And we find that that
creates a rich creativity
to draw upon for the future.
So I think the things
that what's wonderful are
the things about, that Ethel
and Marty and other folks,
you know, like at Appalshop
who built these organizations
at across the country.
Folk arts organizations like us.
They built the process
that that grows and changed
like the U.S. Constitution.
You know, the things
you hear about that.
But it really is a process
and a model that, you know,
it's very malleable
into the future.
So I mean CTMD will
continue to do a lot
of field research
in communities.
We will continue to create
dialogue with communities,
community members and that
dialogue might be involved
different technologies
and things like that
but we're still going
to be talking.
Okay. We're still going to
be doing public programs.
We're still going to be doing
documentation of those programs
and finding ways,
innovative ways
to disseminate that
documentation.
You know, in ways that, you
know, serves the community
and serves the goal of creating
inter community dialogue
and things like that.
So I don't know.
I think it's sort of,
it's hard to project.
I mean a lot of what we do is,
you know, we plan, you know,
and Maureen and I, we plan
or have planning
meetings all the time
and then something happens in
the world and, you know, we're,
you know, riding the tides
that everybody else is.
But you know, I think there's
going to be we'll continue
to do more and more
partnerships with small
and community based
organizations.
Some of those organizations
we may have started 20,
30 years ago and they've created
their own independent paths.
And others are, you
know, newly emerging.
I think, you know, with
technology there's, you know,
new and better ways to
engage with community members
and the general public.
New ways to disseminate
archival materials.
And you know, with especially
getting back a little bit
to archives because I
think that's why we're
here originally.
It's you know, there's, I think,
when you're creating archives
and documentation it's always
important to think about,
well who's the audience
of those materials?
What's going to be the purpose
of those materials, you know?
How do you want the audience
member -- and what are the,
I guess the most -- how do
you make them accessible
in the easiest way.
So our boards been talking.
I'm thinking about that
alongside, you know,
increasing conversations
with our board about how
to get more sophisticated
about segmenting
and targeting particular
audiences.
Finding better ways to create
programs and documentation
that would serve maybe
more targeted portions
of the audience.
And you know, defining
audiences is always interesting.
It's you know, we're serving
community based audiences and,
you know, and there's a
whole diverse spectrum
of folks within communities.
And well, as we're
trying to create programs
that cross bridges
into the general public
or across to other communities.
I mean, I think Marty and Ethel
have always talked about some
of the best projects
and programs
that we've done in our history.
Our programs where half the
audience is from the community
and the other half
is from outside.
Because for the community
members, they get a sense
of validation that all these
outside folks are interested
in what we do and
in our narratives.
And for the outsiders, it's a
great way when you critical mass
of community insiders.
I mean, then you can
really get a window
of how the traditions the,
whether performing arts
or whatever arts,
really fit into a context
within that community.
So that's a great
balance to look at.
But you know, I think, I mean,
looking even farther down.
I mean, I think, there's some
really interesting things
with media technology,
augmented reality.
I mean, you know, now we have
the technology and some of,
a lot of you probably have apps
on your phone where if you hold
up your cell phone to
something being played
over a head it can
actually identify the song.
Well you know, it doesn't go, it
doesn't take too much to connect
that to -- well you can put
lyrics attached to that.
So if you're watching a
performance of Albanian music
in a club and, you know,
in the Bronx or Tirana.
You can hold up your
cell phone and all
of a sudden get a
live translation
of the lyrics and
things like that.
There's all sorts
of, you know --
or get bios of the
performers just
from hearing their voice
and things like that.
So there's going to be a lot of
interesting ways that, I think,
live programming and
documentation are going
to get more and more
integrated in the future.
And through, you know,
different media technologies.
And this this stuff is not
very far away, you know.
And people are already
thinking about this.
>> John Fenn: What do you
guys think about the future?
>> Alexander Gibson:
Unfortunate --
so there's two things I could
politician my way out of this
and answer a different
question than the one was asked.
I could say ditto
because I agree
with everything that
was just said.
But I'll take the third which
I think is just add a couple
other things.
But everything he said I
agree with, I think is true.
I think with Appalshop, you
know, our mission is not
yet satisfied and
is still strong.
It's still applicable,
as applicable today
as it was when it started.
And that's sad in a lot
of ways but expected.
Again, we're just now getting
out of the coal industry which,
you know, politically
marginalizes those that extract
because you need to keep
the cost as low as possible.
So you know, we may
see a new horizon
of Appalachia coming forward.
I don't know that that's true.
I hope that it is.
Economically is what I mean.
And Herb E. and I, we're looking
over the questions before
we came and I was thinking,
you know, seems to
me the only way
that our mission would no longer
-- would need to be revised --
or perhaps Appalshop would
need to close because all
of our staff would not
be oriented in this way.
Would be if Appalachia somehow,
let's say kudzu is this
is this invasive crop.
Let's say kudzu turns
into this delicious wine
that everyone loves and
now -- so if Appalachia,
if that region turned in a
Napa Valley economically,
the context for our work
would be gone, you know,
because of course someone
living in a winery in that part
of the country can
hire their own media
and tell their own story
and other people want
to tell their stories.
So it's fundamentally
about the piece.
It's about being
politically invisible.
Politically marginalized, low
income, and all the effects
and issues that come with that.
So that's really
central to how we think
about our work and
that may change.
Again, we're all hopeful that
it will change but there's
so many barriers at the moment.
And so we try our best
and I'm really hopeful
with this new generation of
young people coming up that are,
again, that may be that
may always be true.
But really politically engaged.
Not as interested in
questions of race and religion.
And they're more interested
in doing work and trying
to create the place that
they want to live in.
So, you know, we just try
to provide the best road
to that destination we can at
Appalshop for the young people
that -- for the most number
of young people that we can.
And it's really -- it's
-- you know, it's --
there's not a lot of
competition in that area,
which is good for
our fundraising.
It's bad for the state, for
the effect that we're seeking.
Yeah.
>> I want to turn it
over to some questions
from the audience now.
We have a little bit of time
here to take any as well
as if you guys have questions
that sort of come up,
we can pitch those as well.
And there are microphones
that are going to be walking
around so we can make sure
that the questions are
captured on the video.
>> So yeah.
I think across the spectrum,
you mentioned the mockery
and the stereotyping, and I know
that was true for my culture,
Yiddish language was just
the stuff of buffoonery.
How do you deal generationally
with the internalized shame
of generation one wanting
to transform their children
into sort of vanilla,
you know, whatever,
and distance themselves
from their own culture?
And I know what you're
talking about.
What you're doing is the
affirming and the validation,
but you almost sometimes have
to fight a generation in order
to get that to happen.
So that's my question.
How do you do that?
Or what do you think about that?
>> Herb E. Smith: Well,
I think it's the --
I think it's the deepest, most
enduring challenge that we have
in Appalachian region today,
is how we free ourselves
from this internalized
oppression.
And the sense of
having to apologize
for who your people are,
how you dress, how you talk,
how your family makes a living
or maybe draws food stamps
or whatever it takes to
survive in those mountains.
Often, there's, with
the survival,
a sense of failure often.
And I want to get past that.
I really do.
I think this sense
of -- I think what --
if there is a consistent goal
for 50 years at Appalshop,
it's trying to deal with that.
>> I have a question also
for Herb E. I'm wondering,
what brought the American Film
Institute to Whitesburg in 1969?
I think George Stevens
Jr. was the head of AFI.
I don't know that he had
a particular interest.
I'm also wondering whether
the Whitesburg Eagle.
It screams, you know, that
was well known at the time.
Did that have anything to do
with why AFI chose Whitesburg?
>> Herb E. Smith: Yeah.
Actually, community
film works --
the AFI [inaudible] community
film workshop Council,
they basically chose
Appalachian one of their places.
At first they didn't choose
Whitesburg but you're right.
The fact that the
Gish's were there and had
that amazing newspaper
was a huge factor in Bill
and Josephine deciding
to move to Whitesburg.
But I think the --
in the larger sense,
I think there was a
realization that we are
in this large diverse country
that we aren't always
recognizing
and that we had a lot
of work to do in terms
of documenting the realities
of life in eastern Kentucky
and southwestern
Virginia and that
that central Appalachian region.
So I think there was an
acknowledgement of that need
that ended up meaning that
people would locate that.
I don't think the
impetus was from AFI.
I think what was happening with
AFI was that they were applying
for funding from the National
Endowment for the Arts
and they needed to show
a more diverse activity
than basically the AFI
staff were, you know,
reflected the reality behind
the cameras at that time,
which was this very
narrow range of people
in the country being represented
in the production
side of things.
And so AFI realized in order --
if you're going to keep getting
federal dollars, you're going
to have to train some
different people to assume some
of the roles in producing
media in this country.
>> Marty mentioned that
at one time at NEA,
the two organizations you
represent were often mentioned
in the same sentence.
And the reality is there
were very few not-for-profits
at that time and that
was indeed the case.
Something that hadn't been
brought up but I think
that was a factor
is that at NEA,
Amy Spelman started an expansion
arts program there and they --
it was mainly to serve
communities of color first
and then expanded to
serve rural organizations.
So that was a factor.
And then at NEA, the
advancement program
and the challenge program
both were put in place
to help organizations develop
and develop funding as well.
Those programs have
disappeared today
and I wondered what your
thinking is in terms
of funding sources
for infrastructure today
for not-for-profits.
Where do you find your money and
what funding streams are there
or not today when you're
looking for support?
>> Peter Rushefsky: I'm the
guy who still wears a tie.
Yeah. No. Barry, right on.
I mean, so much of the sort
of support that was, you know,
either for general operations
or, you know, for infrastructure
like the challenge grants helped
us establish a New York Cultural
Heritage Fund, which is
not a huge endowment,
but at least we have, you
know, some money in the bank.
Go ahead, Ethel.
>> Ethel Raim: Barry was talking
about something even earlier
which was the institutional
advancement grant
which was so crucial.
We had Peggy Delaney
working with us
and talking about,
what are the goals?
What does the organization
look like in ten years?
What are you needs?
I mean, and that was 1979,
and then the first private
foundation support we got was
in '84 from Ford Foundation
because there was someone
who was interested in
what we were doing.
But, Pete, keep going.
>> Peter Rushefsky: Yeah.
And that was Lynn
[inaudible] who supported both.
>> Also funded Appalshop.
Lynn [inaudible]
>> Peter Rushefsky:
Lynn continues
to be on our board too.
So but right.
And so, I mean, so much
of the funding now is really
project-based funding,
and it makes it very tough
when you're, you know,
spinning through a whole
bunch of different, you know,
projects to make sure that
there's enough money carved
out of those, you know, those
not -- never enough grants to,
you know, support operations,
support the development
of the organization, support
things like your website,
support, you know, your office,
you know, whatever support staff
and things like that
and building an archive
until tomorrow.
So it's -- you know, it's --
that's the sort of
conversation we have
with funders all
the time but it's --
you know, I think our field --
I think public folklore in
general could do a better job,
I think, representing
itself as a field
to the funding community.
I think there's a lot of funders
who really don't know what folk
and traditional arts
are really all about.
So I know, you know, NEA is one
great advocate I think we have
to, I think, getting the
word out about, you know,
what the what the field does.
And Cliff has, you know,
been carrying on that
that message very well.
But it's something
we need to keep --
continue to work on
and I think really kind
of get a wider community of
funders to understand not just,
you know, not just -- there's
an urgency to the work because,
you know, a lot of times
we're dealing with traditions
or that may not be around in
another generation unless work
is done in partnership
with the communities
that have helped them
preserve the work --
preserve the artistic
work that they do.
>> Martin Koenig: You
know, after being married
to this organization for so many
years, I finally got married
to a person and it
altered my life.
And, ultimately, what
often happens was I got --
I have three children
and twins came along,
and anyone who knows
anything about twins, I mean,
you're underwater until
they get old enough.
And my wife agreed to have
children if I would spend 50%
of my time bringing them up.
She wasn't going to
do it by herself.
So I left the organization
about 25 years ago,
and once my kids got old enough,
I have gotten back into the work
and I'm working with
the Smithsonian in terms
of doing some publishing
of material
that I had recorded separately
in those first five years
when Margaret Mead supported
the work that I was doing.
So here I am approaching 80
and I forgot what I was
about to talk about.
I didn't mean to --
oh, I know what it is.
Okay. One of the
problems, folks.
So I live on an island
off of Seattle,
and to do this work now, for
Folkways, I have to raise money.
And I made a little 501c3
organization not to burden them
with taking on an additional
thing of what I'm doing
from the other side
of the country.
I am fundraising in a
totally different way.
>> Ethel Raim: It was so
much in my life and not
in the rest of the world, right?
So that was a huge motivation.
You know, and when people start
writing my bios now, they say,
she was at a meeting at
the Newport Foundation
and she said it was a wonderful
festival but I didn't hear any
of the accents that
she grew up with,
that I grew up with,
and it's true.
I didn't. You know, so that was
a big piece of my motivation,
was to really get that kind
of representation and get
that access for those
communities that was
so hidden and now less hidden.
>> I said something
pretty quick.
I had occasion to travel into
some coal mines in Russia,
and what I noticed was
that it was like the 1950s
in those Russian coal mines.
And what became clear
was there was no dissent.
There was nobody challenging
the coal industry in Russia
to change their practices.
They would send 2,000 people
into a Russian coal mine
and we would send 200 people
and we would mine more
than those 2,000 Russian miners.
I said, "What do
they do all day?
They had the same equipment."
And they said, "Well we
-- everybody needs a job."
But, you know, at some point,
you don't want to send everybody
into an underground coal mine
just because they need a job,
so I think this idea
of challenging the prevailing
powers-that-be is really,
really important as we deal
with the realities of a place
that is facing hard times.
>> Is it a short
question, Cliff?
>> Cliff: I'll make it short.
>> Okay.
>> Cliff: So [inaudible] I'd
love just to say congratulations
to Ethel on receiving the
National Heritage Fellowship
and I --
[ Applause ]
And in watching the
slideshow, seeing the number
of National Heritage fellows
that you've advocated,
that your organization
has advocated
for over the years
really is a testament
to your incredible work
on behalf of others.
So thank you for that.
I would say, you
know, just to add
to what Barry Burgee
mentioned earlier,
people still name-check CTMD
and Appalshop at the NEA
when they're talking
about organizations
that they aspire
to be like, right?
In the traditional arts.
And it gets me thinking, you
know, I wonder 50 years in,
right, you could -- if you
were a building, you could be
on the National Register
of Historic Places.
>> Herb E. Smith: I don't
want to be a building.
>> Cliff: So right.
So how is it -- right, see,
there must be a perception.
If people name check you,
they have a perception
of what your organization
is all about in how you work
and who you represent
and how you do it.
And I imagine you must face that
in the communities that you work
in and have been
working in for so long.
So how do you stay nimble?
How do you keep your identity
from ossifying in a way
that enables you to work
with so many different types
of people and perspectives?
Is that a short question?
>> Yes but the answer is long.
>> I mean, you know I said it's
come up in a couple of her ways
and you guys, but
they both hit on it.
The founders established a
process for working the people
and I think that process has
allowed agility is what I've
been hearing across the panels.
And so it's not like you
set out with the blueprint
if you're just going to
do this and you do it
through thick or thin.
You -- is that it?
>> Peter Rushefsky:
Right, right.
Well, I mean, luckily
there's been no shortage
of new communities moving to
New York City and great artists
that nobody knows that
may be driving taxis
or working restaurant shifts
late at night or tending bar or,
you know, doing what we've got,
you know, wonderful artists
who are grave diggers
during the day.
And so anytime we start worrying
about that, we just open
up our eyes and ears realize
that there's just new --
more and more folks who
are continuing to come
to the country, coming
to the city.
But, you know, also, you know,
the organizations are adapting.
I mean, some of the
artists we work with now,
they're way more sophisticated
with social media than we --
anybody on our staff is.
I mean, and so I think the
dialogues that get created
with the artists and the
community members were --
I mean, they're the most
invigorating thing we can do
as an organization is just have
those dialogues because it's
through them that we find
out about great new ways
that they're applying
their artistry,
things that are changing
in the communities
that we never imagined,
you know, how the --
a lot of the communities
are really --
it's very much post diasporic,
I guess, or whatever you --
however you want to call it.
But there's -- they're
not just --
they're no longer separated
from their home communities.
They're very much --
>> They're transnational.
>> Peter Rushefsky:
Transnational and
things like that.
So I think it's --
I mean, we're --
as much as we're creating
a lot of these programs,
we're sort of --
we're benefiting from the
creativity that's already there
and already existing in these
communities and we're, you know,
trying to channel
that into, you know,
in ways that we hope
serves the community
and serves the greater
public in creating dialogue.
>> You guys have something?
>> Alexander Gibson: Yeah.
Because of the work
that folks like Herb E.
and the founders did, you
know, Appalshop, when it puts
out a call for a new
job, gets applications
from all over the country.
And so we were able to get a lot
of people that help diversify
and rejuvenate our practice.
One example of that -- and
that's part of the process.
And the other thing I would say
before I give the example is
that we've always had
community members.
We've never had a
professional board.
It's always been a mix of
workers and community members.
I think that's been
really important.
Our current board chair is a
longtime advocate for justice
in the region and so she --
and she's also never
worked at Appalshop
so it's very interesting.
And her brother is a -- also
works now with Appalshop
and is very conservative and --
anyway, so it's always been
an interesting balance.
So the example I'll give is
that we have a person who came
and interviewed for a community
development job and his job was
to go around and
organize basically.
I didn't give him
the title organizer
because that title makes me
nervous, but fundamentally,
that's what he's doing.
And it's in this context of
wealth and power and control
and new future and where's
coal and where are we
and are we deciding and can we
partner in new power structures,
can we create new
economic linkages?
So during the interview,
the guy struck me
as perhaps having
some challenges.
Now, we had a lot of
interviews for this.
He came from Connecticut.
He was very different.
He had pocket -- he
had things on his --
elbow patches, you know,
like professors have.
He had a doctorate
in organizing.
He quoted Saul Alinsky all the
time and he opens his meetings
by saying, "I'm a
communist Jew from New York
and I'm here to work."
And then when he's
challenged on it, he says,
"Well, that's not true.
There are no good communist
parties in Kentucky."
And he's been incredibly
successful
as an organizer in the region.
Incredibly successful.
I think he's more
well-liked then most anybody
and by the community, and that's
how he opens up his meetings.
It's interesting.
But Appalshop, by, I think,
by continual, you know,
bringing in new people.
Like I said, we don't
pay them enough,
so at some point they
go off somewhere else.
But that's been the way that
I think we've most been able
to stay agile is the integration
of new people with new ideas
and the particular mentality of
Appalachian people which, again,
if we get in -- if we got into
a big discussion of racism,
I could go into,
but fundamentally there's
this kind of, you know,
you prove yourself
to me through time.
I can count on you.
You show up when you say
you're going to show up.
You're good.
Versus this this
initial, you know,
I haven't seen someone
like you before.
You have things on your pockets.
You know, now you need to show
up a couple times
before I trust you
or maybe your skin's too
dark or maybe you're a woman
or maybe you're Muslim.
So these are the challenges
that, you know, that we face,
but I think that's
how we've been able
to maintain agility is one
in the structure and then two
in the recruitment of new
and interesting people
that bring different approaches.
>> Herb E. Smith: And I must
say, we did realize as elders
that we had to stay
out of their way.
>> Alexander Gibson: Most
of them have realized that.
Yeah.
>> Well, on that note,
we're going to get
out of the way of
the next panelist.
I want to thank you all.
[ Applause ]
And I'm going to suggest we'll
start the next panel five
minutes later than we planned,
so it'll be like 3:05 just
to give to people time
to reboot and refresh.
So thank you very much.